rather than confronting these questions
directly my interests you to avoid the
specifics of these struggles and instead
except heavy industrial processes in
combination with natural materials I let
my career's to open up my vision
questioning how things are made
exploring contradiction by experimenting
with the physics of forms and materials
this contradiction comes through in my
use of skeletal armatures combined with
decorations a technical find integral to
my three-dimensional problem solving
process it also allows me to treat
material and form letting what with
trouble appears fragile in my work night
technique and my subject matter come
from my interest in treating all
substances informally as raw materials
for example iron fists together fiscal
manufactured steel and plastic resin in
defiance of their usual symbolic
definitions guided by my own intuitive
understanding of the place and meaning
at the same time I'm also inspired by
the mastercraft person who often claims
has materiality dies or even speak to
them in some sort of quasi religious
fashion my milk suggests how I don't see
contradiction between the logical
preparation of engineering and my inner
experience feelings perceptions and
imagination
you